- Étienne Lapointe s'est trouvé
un nouvel appartement qui lui
convient mieux. Il sait
qu'un déménagement équivaut
souvent à une hausse de loyer
pour le locataire qui suivra.
- On est conscient des enjeux,
puis on sait que les loyers
augmentent à Montréal.
- En effet, dans la dernière
année, le loyer moyen de
l'ensemble des appartements
locatifs de la région
métropolitain de Montréal a
augmenté de 6 %, la plus forte
hausse depuis près de 30 ans.
MAXIME ROY-ALLARD, Regroupement
des comités logement du Québec
- À Montréal, c'est vraiment
une situation critique. Je pense
qu'on est en train de perdre
la bataille du logement
abordable. Ce n'est pas normal
que les loyers augmentent
de 5 % - 6 % par année,
alors que l'inflation est autour
de 1 % - 2 %. Il y a quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas.
- Étienne opte donc pour
une cession de bail qui permet
à un candidat qu'il sélectionne
de reprendre son bail aux mêmes
conditions, et surtout, au même
prix de loyer. Mais il rencontre
rapidement de la résistance
de la part de sa gestionnaire
d'immeuble.
ÉTIENNE LAPOINTE locataire
- C'était quand même une fin
de non recevoir. C'est plutôt
catégorique de son côté.
"On ne fait pas ça, désolée."
- Après une première tentative
d'envoi par lettre recommandée
infructueuse, Étienne décide
d'avoir recours à un huissier
pour s'assurer que l'avis
de cession de bail
est bien reçue.
- C'est sûr que c'est un peu
stressant tout ce processus-là.
J'aurais préféré que ça se passe
plus facilement.
- Étienne a finalement reçu,
après notre première rencontre,
une lettre de sa gestionnaire
d'immeuble invoquant notamment
des  réparations majeures
à faire dans l'édifice pour
refuser la demande d'Étienne.
On lui offre trois mois de loyer
pour qu'il opte plutôt pour
la résiliation de son bail.
ANTOINE MORNEAU-SÉNÉCHAL
avocat en droit du logement
- Il faut que les locataires
sachent que la cession de bail
c'est un droit qui leur
appartient, et qu'à moins
d'un motif sérieux,
comme l'insolvabilité
de la personne ou des mauvais
antécédents de la personne
à qui on veut céder le bail,
ça ne peut pas être refusé."
- Étienne n'est pas le seul
à vouloir faire une cession
de bail présentement.
Ce militant pour le droit
des locataires observe un
engouement pour cette pratique.
- Il y a beaucoup de locataires
qui s'intéressent à ce moyen-là
pour trouver des logements, pour
lutter contre les hausses
de loyers abusives.
- Claudia Leduc gère des groupes
Facebook comme " J'te cède mon
bail" de plus en plus
populaires.
CLAUDIA LEDUC gestionnaire gr.
Fb qui aident les locataires
- On voit l'efficacité
de ces groupes en ce moment.
Il faut qu'on reprenne notre
pouvoir en temps que locataire
parce que on n'en a. Et l'un
des plus importants qu'on a,
c'est de pouvoir faire
une cession de bail.
- Mais de son côté, le porte-
parole de la Corporation
des propriétaires immobiliers
du Québec dénonce ce mouvement
qu'il qualifie de syndicalisme
locataire. Les propriétaires
doivent, selon lui, avoir
la liberté d'augmenter le loyer
au prix du marché.
HANS BROUILLETTE, dir. affaires
publiques Corpo. propriétaires
- Il va falloir que la loi
change, que ce soit
politiquement ou via un recours
judiciaire parce que il n'est
pas acceptable que locataire
puisse forcer une cession de
bail alors que le propriétaire
peut très bien être prêt à le
libérer ce locataire sans avoir
à payer davantage.
- Étienne est bien décidé
à aller de l'avant avec
sa cession de bail,
malgré les obstacles.
- J'ai pris rendez-vous
au tribunal du logement pour
poursuivre la cession de bail
parce que c'est quelque chose
d'important puis je veux
continuer ce combat-là.
- Ici Fannie Bussières McNicoll,
Radio-Canada, Mo